machine gun kelly wants to put a ring on
it yes a source tells e.t that the
musician is planning to propose to
girlfriend megan fox and apparently mgk
hasn't been keeping it a secret the
source tells e.t that he's been telling
his friends about his plans to pop the
question adding quote they're very in
love and beyond obsessed with each other
they're ready to take this next step in
their relationship i don't want to lose
that feeling there's no denying megan
and mgk have great chemistry just last
month they showed off their playful vibe
while taking a couple's quiz for gq
what's my favorite movie now i can't
wait for it to get cold and i'm going to
make it no no no no you don't you don't
have to you don't have to go there it's
like an eight series piece we're talking
about hairy mother
potter yes don't think that i'm not
my favorite obviously prisoners of
azkaban the couple even shared details
about their first date looking over to
penga canyon
and we ate
sushi we shared a kiss
and our our first date
our first date we breathed each other
that was all we did they also revealed
their cute nicknames for each other
buddha
lambie you haven't gotten that one in a
long while but you gotta earn that one
back cookie
blonde angel baby
megan and mgk who started dating in 2020
have never been shy about showing off
their romance especially on the red
carpet which et saw first hand at the
2021 vmas are you proud of him very
proud he's the most talented boy in the
world megan you guys look awesome we'll
be back
i don't know if this is family friendly
y'all
now it's no surprise that the couple
want to take this next step just last
month the two got candid with british gq
about their intense connection the
actress explained quote i did not
anticipate walking right into my soul
mate like that meeting him it's like
meeting your own soul's reflection he's
so charismatic and he's so naturally
gifted
and he's so intense
as for mgk well he says it's actually
his first time being in love quote it's
like because you've been around the
world and experienced so much
you think you know everything and then
you are in the arms of your destiny and
realize i don't know yet it's hard to
top that one man
[Music]